Hallo hallo BAU BAU!
It's time for FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning hajimaru yo!
BAU BAU!
I'm a chihuahua, I'm Fuwawa!
I'm not Fuwawa, I'm Mococo!
Together we are FUWAMOCO!
BAU BAU!
And today, we're your host of FUWAMOCO Morning!
Ruffians!
Thank you for joining us today for our 24th episode!
BAU BAU BAU!
A new day, Moco-chan.
A new day.
Do you think we're ready?
If not us, hopefully the Ruffians are.
And if you're not, then we'll make you ready.
Well, for any first time Ruffians, FUWAMOCO Morning is a short format morning show
Every Friday, Wednesday, and Monday.
AKA FUWAMOCO.
And it's hosted by us, FUWAMOCO!
Our aim is to bring a smile to your face and help you start your day off on the right paw.
Please tweet your thoughts with the hashtag #FWMCMORNING, okay?
Now let's all BAU BAU to a brand new FUWAMOCO Morning!
BAU BAU!
Moco-chan, has there been another Pero Sighting?
There has been!
Well, I wonder, did this Ruffian seem on Mars again still?
Is she still on Mars?
It seems that Pero's a...
Mama Pero.
I don't know, this kind of looks like the nest a mama bird would have.
Are those babies?
Four babies!
Oh my gosh.
Pero were toyed.
Actually though, if you kind of look at them...
Cute, right, Ruffians?
I guess they're kinda cute, right?
They're all different, you know?
They all have their own unique traits, you know?
There's one with much bigger ears than the rest of them.
Just like me to you, Moco-chan, right?
There's one that's a bit rounder?
A bit smiley?
No, it's not me!
No.
I don't know though, I don't think you should be taking any of them from the nest.
If Pero's a chill mama and anything like we know Pero to be normally, then you might regret it.
I still don't really know what I'm looking at, but is it one of those things where if you give your eyes a good rub and blink twice it just goes away like a dream?
Ruffians, let's give our eyes a good rub, okay?
Do wake up.
Wake up, wake up, wake up, wake up, wake up, wake up, wake up.
It's gone.
Thank goodness.
I guess it was a dream, huh?
Just sleeping.
Get to sleep all your life, you know?
It doesn't really make sense for Pero to be a mama bear, you know?
Pero is Pero, right?
It must have just been a particularly bad dream, right?
Ruffians!
Let us know if you see Pero around again, okay?
But maybe not something as deceiving as this last one was.
You can let us know with the hashtag #FWMCMORNING!
Thank you!
BAU BAU!
You couldn't see that, Ruffians.
You just want to rub your eyes, right?
Well, on the topic of rubbing your eyes, we have a bit of sad news.
More personal sad news.
You know, in case you saw on Twitter last night, you might know, but... Unfortunately, we weren't really able to sleep last night.
It's the worst, you know?
It's such a waste of time.
No matter what, we both just couldn't fall asleep.
You know, you might think it's weird, like, well, if Moco-chan can't sleep, then Fuwawa should be able to sleep, but... Right, it's not like that.
I don't know why.
You know, we both even took a nice bath after Planetarian Eats to get all toasty and comfy and ready for bed.
You know...
I even... I used my favorite bath salts for it.
Just to make us extra sleepy.
Moco-chan let me use them too.
Right?
But... It didn't work.
No?
No!
You know, it's the worst when you can't sleep because there's so many things you'd rather do rather than just lie in bed and try to sleep.
Like you have to do this and that and this, but you're trying to sleep, so...
We could be doing so many other things with our time, and we have lots of homework to do today, so there's not really any time to take a nap or anything.
No time to sleep again.
You know, it's times like that where I can't sleep in the middle of the night.
I look at what's going on with the Ruffians, so... But I know that the Ruffians did have a lot of interesting suggestions on how to get to sleep.
Right?
Right, Ruffians?
Like what?
Like some Ruffians suggested hot milk.
Which I played it before, you know?
Hot milk to get to sleep.
I don't know.
It just sounds...
Not like something that would be very appetizing.
It doesn't seem right enough.
It seems like it wouldn't calm me down.
Like, hot milk is good in tea.
But, I don't think otherwise is very... It just sounds like bleh.
Yeah, I don't know.
I guess I can kind of understand, but... Like, other things that the Ruffians suggested, though, is like... Getting McDonald's?
Is that real?
Milk sounds bad, yeah.
Yeah, I don't know.
McDonald's, I feel like that just might make you feel a bit more awake, but I guess it could also be like a fun middle of the night adventure.
If you're a brave person, you can go outside, right?
I do feel like it would be fun, but I think my tummy might keep me up after that.
Is that a normal thing?
Is it normal?
I don't know if it's normal.
I don't think that's the best idea.
I thought it was... It sounds interesting.
It sounds fun, but... Yeah, I don't know if it's the most practical.
Water is good, you know.
If you have something like McDonald's and milk, you gotta brush your teeth again.
But there was also one other really good suggestion too, Moco-chan.
A lullaby from a Ruffian.
I like that one.
Lullaby for FUWAMOCO.
It sounds cute.
I sort of want to tinkle that more when I can't fall asleep in the future.
You know, when I'm trying to fall asleep.
Thank you, love you for the good suggestions.
Please be there for us when it's difficult sometimes, okay?
BAU BAU!
Even if we had a little bit of sad news, there's been some good news too!
Koyori-senpai hit 1 million subscribers!
BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU!
Congratulations, Koyori-senpai!
The other day, our canine and precious senpai, Koyori-senpai, just reached 1 million subscribers on YouTube.
Huge accomplishment.
We all know that she's been working very hard to reach that goal.
FUWAMOCO, we're so happy that the dream has come true for you too.
I hope that, you know, maybe one day we can collab and maybe we can say BAU BAU WAO!
BAU BAU WAO!
Congrats, Kuri-senpai!
This is truly a crazy stream of us.
Yeah, I don't think we'll ever be anything close to her, but we'll do our best in our own FUWAMOCO way.
BAU BAU!
Kuri-senpai, omedetou!
It's good to have happiness.
Sad news with happiness.
No more sad news.
Unless there's been a... A bit of a misunderstanding.
Maybe.
Just a little maybe.
Yeah.
There's been a misunderstanding.
I don't know.
Maybe it's small enough that the Ruffians didn't notice?
I don't know, maybe.
We thought that we should maybe let you know, but over the weekend, it was Mumei-senpai's 3D showcase, right?
No misunderstandings there, right?
Happy!
It's happy, you know?
Moco-chan, we should say another big congrats, right?
Congratulations!
It was really really wonderful.
We really liked the emotional final song that Iyami-senpai sang too.
But during it, she had a song that she sang together with Poka-senpai, right?
Did it surprise you as much as it surprised us?
You know, at the end of their performance together, Pouka-senpai went in for a sudden hug from Mumei-senpai, right?
Right, right.
And, uh, we're a bit surprised, right?
And so, Moco-chan, you commented that hug.
Dot, dot, dot, dot, dot, dot.
Dot?
With six dots!
Yeah.
Maybe, you know, maybe some Ruffians, some adventures maybe misunderstood that to be jealous or happy, but that definitely wasn't it, right?
Misunderstanding.
Right, Moco-chan?
It's a misunderstanding.
It definitely, definitely wasn't that.
You know, it was just because I was surprised and touched.
Yeah.
Right, right, right.
I was just happy for Mumei-senpai that she got a hug from Polka-oneechan.
You know, yeah.
Exactly that, right?
Yeah, yeah.
Not because I didn't get a hug from Polka, onee-chan.
No, I know.
I know I can't remember one day I wasn't with you, but maybe I forgot to give you a hug.
What?
Yeah.
Happy Bume-senpai Howl!
Happy that Bume-senpai got a howl, I guess.
Good 3D Showcase!
Congratulations on the 3D Showcase, Mimei-senpai!
What did Moco-chan just say?
You heard me.
BAU BAU!
Not a misunderstanding.
Moco-chan's brain didn't break at all.
No, right?
No.
Well...
I have, maybe... You have something you have to say, right?
I don't have to say this.
It's embarrassing, Moco-chan.
It's time for you to confess.
I have a confession, Ruffians.
It's embarrassing though.
I'm still a puppy, but not this much a puppy.
Ruffians, you know, some days it's hard to control ourselves, right?
BAU BAU.
When we go for a good walk, naturally we see other dogs on the walk.
You know, just like any Ruffian.
Sometimes they're cute, maybe a bit fluffy, maybe a bit fuzzy.
But the other day, we crossed paths with one dog that was especially fluffy.
And what did you do with it?
Do I have to say, Moco-chan?
Fuwawa accidentally started BAU BAUing at it.
I just couldn't help it!
It was so cute, so fluffy!
She went BAU BAUing!
Ruffians, that happens to you sometimes too, right?
You know, you pass by a cute dog, you just get so excited that you can't stop yourself from BAU BAUing!
Right?
Yes!
Let's do our best together.
Understandable.
No!
Don't!
I think no is more reasonable.
No is more reasonable.
I feel like a rose.
Ruffians, you need to try to act cool here.
You should say yes, you know?
I guess it's lucky because Moco-chan stopped me before I lost myself.
It's a good thing I'm here, right?
I guess it could have been pretty bad.
I'm a good guide dog!
I've trained a lot!
I guess I'm still just a puppy, right?
I'll do better next time.
So don't let the BAU BAU wheel get to you, okay?
Fuwawa and the Ruffians.
Let's stay in control together, okay?
Stay in control.
Alright, how did I react?
No Fuwawa, no BAU BAU!
Like that.
No BAU BAU!
Yeah.
It's hard when they're cute and fluffy.
And that's the end of FUWAMOCO Morning!
What are you announcing?
It's the end!
No!
No, it's the start of a new week, right Ruffians?
And the start of a new week means that we got to challenge ourselves to something new, right?
Right.
Ruffians, you have a good idea of what you're gonna challenge, right?
And Moco-chan, I think Moco-chan does too because you know we're gonna start the week off with a bang and Moco-chan is going to be continuing to challenge herself to eat natto!
Moco-chan, you're ready, right?
You know, I haven't slept, so then my tummy is extra extra.
And that's exactly why you need to have some natto then.
Ruffians, this is Moco-chan's third time trying to eat natto on FUWAMOCO Morning, but there still might be some Ruffians that don't really know what natto is.
So to explain, it's a very common breakfast food in Japan that's made of fermented soybeans.
And yeah, fermented soybeans can be rather sticky and slimy and maybe a bit strong smelling too.
But it's really really healthy for you.
I want to be able to eat it because it's healthy for you.
I feel like right now is not the time to challenge myself.
Right now I need headbutts.
Not until you eat it.
But!
So!
Moco-chan is going to conquer her dislike for natto so that she can continue to protect
You'll smile for many, many years to come.
Right, Moco-chan?
I'll do my best.
And in that way, you can become just like her older sister, Fuwawa, who eats it happily every day.
Yeah.
Actually, Ruffians, I thought that maybe today I'd let Moco-chan use soy sauce on it.
But... no.
No.
We all know that I'm gonna have to eat it later today.
And I don't want soy sauce on it, so... She's going to have to eat it straight.
And today, last time on the... I did good last time.
You ate one bean.
I did good!
I don't know.
So today, Moco-chan's goal is... No way, Miki!
Go again!
Because it's healthy.
I'm gonna stay on you.
And I don't know why every time you choose the chopsticks that I hate the most.
I don't like the texture of the chopsticks.
Okay, just... Moco-chan, shush.
Shush!
Can you hear it?
Mix, mix, mix.
Ah, it's nice and stood and over.
Renato is happy to do it.
Renato is ready for the week.
Ready to go into Moco-chan's tummy.
Okay, Moco-chan.
First, first, first, first, first.
Let's say thank you to the farmers in Tochigi who worked very hard.
You worked twice.
I'm sorry, I don't like it as much as other people.
Okay, Moco-chan.
I'm really... Let her use her favorite chopsticks.
No!
She needs to become a big... Moco-chan, what are you doing?
Angry sounds.
Are you making a lip-sucking sound?
Wow, Moco-chan.
I want you to clean off the chopsticks.
I'm not gonna clean them off!
Can I wipe them off with my tissue?
No!
No, if you put it in your mouth, then it'll be... No.
Wiped off then.
No, I'm gonna use the tissue.
No, Moco-chan.
You're so weak.
I'm weak right now.
I didn't sleep, okay?
I'm weak.
Now I got tissue all over the chopsticks too.
I'd rather eat tissue.
Look what you've done.
Wait, Moco-chan, you'd rather eat tissue than natto?
Probably.
Not as healthy, but... No, it won't be healthy at all.
Moco-chan, you have to do more than just look at it.
Okay, this is three beans in one.
Let me inspect it first.
It's three beans.
It is three beans.
That is three beans.
Moco-chan is not lying.
And there's some good stings going.
Not enough though!
There could be more.
This is three beans.
The smell is already getting to me and it doesn't usually get to me.
But you're getting used to it now.
Ruffians, I need help.
I'm gonna put down the chopsticks.
No, you should keep it close to your face.
You almost pushed the beans into my lap!
Ready?
Ready!
Okay, Moco-chan, we're gonna count down from five this time, Ruffians!
You will give me the tea this time, right?
Five!
No, no, no, no, no, no, no.
You will give me the tea, you promise, right?
You promise.
Why should I tell Ruffians?
She's gonna promise.
Ruffians, should I give Moco-chan some tea or not?
She can't reach it.
Her paws are too short.
I didn't sleep, please.
Ah.
Yes!
Tea allowed.
Yes, yes.
I see some gnaw.
Give her the tea.
I'd like to see all my gnaw.
What?
Gnaw.
Okay!
I guess I'll gnaw Moco-chan.
Okay, last time I chewed it.
And that wasn't a good... You should chew it.
But you chew it.
You chew it right.
I chew it.
Ah, but you can also just swallow it too.
Ah.
I feel like chewing it wasn't a great option, but I don't know what's better.
It's healthier if you chew because then your tummy will be happy.
Chew it.
Chewing is better.
As long as it's chewing.
Yeah, I think so too.
Okay!
I have to take deep breaths, okay.
This is three, Moco-chan!
FUWAMOCO Morning's gonna end again!
No!
This is three, okay?
Give me the credit for three, okay?
Okay!
Three small ones.
Three, okay.
Five!
No, no, no, wait.
Four!
Wait, wait, wait!
Three!
No, please stop!
Two!
No, no, no, I'm not ready for this!
Moco-chan!
Wait, wait, wait!
Do I have another tissue?
No, you can't.
This is the only tissue you get.
Oh, I've got another tissue.
What?
Okay.
Okay, here we go for good, Ruffians.
Ruffians are gonna get tired of pressing 5.
From 10, then.
They can press 10.
This is your third time.
That's just pathetic.
There's three 10s, okay?
No.
5!
No, no, no!
I need more time!
My heart needs to get ready, okay?
We're gonna press 10, okay?
My sister's just too pathetic. 10!
9, 8, 7, 6, 5, 4, 3, 2, 1!
Oh, oh, oh.
Moco-chan button!
The doggy button took it out!
I feel like I can't do this today.
They are just soybeans.
I feel like I can't.
Are you gonna let the beans beat you?
What?
Don't let the beans beat you.
I don't wanna let the beans beat me.
Okay.
Three!
Two!
One!
Ruffians!
I'm saying I can do it!
Why am I even bothered?
No, I'm not defeated by beans!
I can beat the beans, okay?
I'm not gonna count down.
I'm not gonna count down anymore.
I haven't done it.
Do you deserve the tea anymore?
I do deserve the tea!
Better eat it fast, otherwise no tea!
Okay.
Stop touching her toge!
I'm doing my best.
Okay, I'm gonna do my best!
For the Ruffians!
For Porocom-nen-chan!
I just need a hug.
What's in there?
It's in there!
Moco-chan, eat it!
Eat it!
The stings, I can see the stings.
I touched Moco-chan's mouth.
What is this sound?
Moco-chan, that's no good!
You want the beans to beat you, huh?
Not today.
Not today!
Can I have tea still, please?
No, you don't deserve it!
You didn't do anything, they just went in there.
The beans won, huh?
The bean's bigger.
I want tea!
No tea.
Don't cry, Moco-chan.
It's tearing!
No.
Moco-chan, it's okay because you know what's next?
A regular corner so you can forget about the apple, forget about the beans.
Just savor the taste in your mouth.
Maybe for a little bit longer.
Cough drop.
Goodbye.
Thank you, Tochigi.
My little sister is so weak.
We're guard dogs, Moco-chan.
You can't let some silly natto beat you.
FUWAMOCO-chan, who's the Doggie of the Day today?
I don't know.
This is Ozzy!
You're good at breaking just like me, huh?
Nato broke you, Nato-chan.
Hi!
I almost called Moco-chan Nato-chan.
Why would you call me that?
You just want to hurt me, don't you?
Well, Nato-chan, what do you think?
He's breaking, like breakdancing, right?
That's what I look like when I'm broken, too.
Yeah, I don't know.
Yeah, maybe not so much dancing.
Maybe he's kind of broken, too.
But you know, he's cute.
I bet you he's crying.
He's doing his best, so... Like me.
Not like Moco-chan.
Or Nato-chan.
Not like Nato-chan.
No!
Yeah, but...
Ozzy.
Such a cutie.
Moco-chan, how does he BAU BAU?
Does maybe he sing along with the music while he breaks?
I feel like his BAU BAU would be... Not two BAU BAUs.
Just one BAU BAU.
One BAU BAU at a time.
Along with the music maybe?
You know, Ozzy is very silly and has a bit of a creative side, I think.
Just like me.
And you know, I think Ozzy, not only do they want to impress you with their breakdown skills, but also...
I think they want to show how much they want to protect you, you know?
They love you!
Just like me.
So, make sure you don't get too mad if maybe the dancing gets a bit out of hand sometimes.
Don't get too mad at me.
BAU BAU!
Next!
Did a Ruffian go on a walk?
De-den!
Oho!
Look at the leaves!
I can smell the photo.
The green all these way!
I can see that you can almost smell how fresh and crisp the air is.
It doesn't smell like natto.
It wouldn't smell like natto, right?
But you know, I can't believe how fast the seasons are changing, you know?
It's almost the end of September, Ruffians!
Do you believe it?
Are we sure it's not August?
I feel like it's the beginning of August.
No.
I feel like it is.
It's really gone by so, so fast.
Don't say that!
Don't say that, okay?
It's not fall.
It's autumn, isn't it?
You know, I hope you had a really great one.
Maybe you bundled up a little bit because it's getting pretty chilly out maybe.
Maybe you had an even greater brunch too.
BAU BAU!
Wow, what's our question of the day?
Our question of the day is... Recently, I've noticed how many bad habits I've formed in my life over the years.
I want to break these habits and be a better person for FUWAMOCO.
Thank you, my... I'm sure you're fine just the way you are, too.
But it's always good to, you know, want to be a little bit of a new dog, too, right?
Challenge yourself, right?
Even on days when you feel like you can't challenge new things.
Even on those days, too.
Extra good on those days.
I challenged it.
It didn't go well, though.
You can do it, Ruffians!
Moco-chan took a bullet today for you.
But what are some bad habits that you girls have had, and how did you overcome them?
Or did you overcome them?
I guess one of my bad habits is that I'm kind of picky when it comes to food.
Is that a bad habit?
Isn't that just normal?
We're a bit picky.
We have a funny sense of taste, maybe, so... Maybe just a bit.
That's not something that... In some areas, we're not gonna overcome that.
FUWAMOCO's FUWAMOCO, but not always an area Moco-chan's gonna overcome, right?
That's the point.
That's the goal.
But you know, other bad habits...
I guess, I think you could say we used to be really bad perfectionists, you know?
It's not very good.
You know, they say, don't let perfect be the enemy of good, right?
And that's exactly it.
You know, if you want to be perfect all the time, you'll never get anything done.
You'll just be frozen in fear, right?
So just do!
Don't think!
Just do it.
It might not be great at first, but that's okay.
I feel like as long as it's fun, then that's good enough, you know?
And you'll get better just by doing it, so... Even though it might be tough to kind of just forget about those feelings, but... It's a bit uncomfy, right?
Do it!
Just forget about them.
Remember, nobody can be perfect.
Perfect is boring too you know.
And there's a lot of beauty in our imperfections too.
So just be yourself and do your best.
And please don't think that FUWAMOCO is perfect because that's not true at all.
We're not perfect.
We don't wake up on time all the time.
We have grumpy days.
You know, sometimes we just can't do it.
But we do our best!
And that's all we can do.
Exactly.
You know, I think we have gotten much better with perfectionism.
We aren't really like that anymore, but we do have a certain way of doing things that we like to do.
We're a bit stubborn.
Also, you know, they say it's not good to have a phone beside you when you're in bed, right?
But it's tricky because what wakes you up?
It's tough.
Yeah.
I would like to not look at it an hour before bed.
Yeah, we've been trying, but still not quite there, right?
Maybe that's a challenge that we could try to take on together, Ruffians!
BAU BAU!
Thank you for the questions!
Ruffians, we're always looking for more submissions, so please ask us your questions, your works, all those things!
We'll be waiting!
BAU BAU!
And our next stream!
We have De-den!
Well, tonight we're going to be shifting gears a little bit to focus on some of our homework and recording that we absolutely need to get done.
Tomorrow we're going to be having a collab stream with Calli-senpai!
She's prepared a very special game show where we'll be going head to head, paw to paw, to see just what twins are really like, and to see how similar, maybe how different we are, right?
I wonder, Ruffians, maybe we'll find out something shocking.
We'll have to see.
BAU BAU!
And before we go, let's take a quick peek at our schedule.
On Wednesday.
Fuwawa is going to be doing her first solo stream.
I'll be challenging myself this week too.
Maybe this week's theme is challenge.
I feel like that's every week.
It should be the theme every week.
Not just that though.
I'll be hunting ghosts on my own and having claustrophobia.
Good luck!
Thanks Moco-chan, that doesn't mean much from you.
Ruffians, could you please help me lots?
Yeah, I want to be able to level up to become a stronger guard dog, you know?
And maybe hopefully make a little bit of money so I can buy more of the strong flashlights.
Yeah, those are important, right?
Yeah, you know, that way I'm not that scared.
I'll be scared, but it'll be maybe a little bit helpful.
Please, Ruffians, please be there to help hold my paw, okay?
BAU BAU.
We have lots of fun things to do.
Please join us for more guys too!
BAU BAU!
Well, Moco-chan, another FUWAMOCO Morning comes to an end, and it hasn't been 20 minutes at all.
But we have still one more thing!
Oh, what's this?
A black box with a question mark?
Question.
Oh.
Well, maybe some of the doggy packs should keep their eyes open tonight for something special.
But don't look forward to it that much.
It's just something.
I don't know.
It might be cool.
It's up to you.
That's why there's a question mark on it.
That's why there's a question mark.
BAU BAU!
While we started a new week together, FUWAMOCO Morning has come to an end.
But before we say BAU BAU for now, we'd like to shout out to some of our Extra Special Ruffians today!
Yami-sama!
BAU BAU!
Icarus.
Mixed-Things Boy.
BAU BAU!
Toumei.
Kyontama.
BAU BAU!
Memora.
Helio.
BAU BAU!
Wand of You.
Shoji.
BAU BAU!
To every other Ruffian out there, we hope you have a howl of a day!